[Applauso]
sì sì è vero si stava già attive per mac
street store ed oggi slime con delle
mister in seconda posizione da questa
scatola top magari comunque no non ci
sono dolci contesto capo invito ai box
ci sono gli ingredienti per lo slime in
ogni scatola sono diversi e in alcuni ci
sono ingredienti berti quindi quando
vuoi e chi capiteranno vedere nostre
prove svizzere per bene anche questa
volta come funziona questa challenge
in pratica dobbiamo scegliere una
scatola testa allora la 2 3 4 5 6 che
poi perde con stop talk che non si
vedono bene ma le scatole bellissime con
ricorda le foglie
poi dovremo fare con slide con gli
ingredienti che ci sono capitati dentro
le scatole e alla fine del video come
sempre dovrete dirci chi ha vinto tra me
e vitale in mostra la bellezza dello zen
vederne stavolta chi troppo bella è che
se volete vedere altre ad esistere e
fateci sapere come si pone a testa alla
classifica sono ferme e ora siete
proprio batti e corri
mettetevi comodi iniziamo subito allora
praticamente le scatole non preparate io
sono ovviamente tutti i condomini
momento il quale numero messo quale però
fare tre correnti 32 scegliere sempre la
scatola è io prenderò un altra quindi
fra la roma da due pale secchi
ok premi ma io prendo la 1 per ora sono
qua poi rimontare lampo link frate da
quattro quale semi a 694 ok ombretto
nostre grazie alla 65 e franco marini
spain ho preso due varietà di semi
cascata uniforme scatola bologna con
outlook da quello con un ritorno alla
terra
ah sì ok ok abbiamo le nostre scatole
ora iniziamo con il primo unboxing della
prima casa
senza testa e casa riscatto dopo crisi
due iniziano dalla prima che abbiamo
pescato quindi per me era uno che ha
privato che colore ma oggi un pezzo di
cioccolato no dai tiratori color verde
lime allora in realtà ordinato dei nuovi
colorati che hanno dei colori
stranissimi c'è qualcos'altro questo non
è verde ma è il colore lime quel flusso
per curioso di vederla non lo slime
ormai fa sempre più al sito secondo me
lo farò diventare bellissimo con questo
dolore dei clipper colorati gialli loro
devo dire fuori da vantaggi e frangia di
euro allora vi io e il color pesca e
dove non perdonerà se pietro l'altra sel
che non vedo l'ora di vedere come sarà
il color pesca nello slime sicuramente
diverso da quello che si vede qualcosa
troppo rosso
non credo che le ripeteva il color pesca
e poi dei l'inter o bertin
rosa ti piace
aspetto predonomia prezzi quale è
capitata stiamo delle città che d'oro di
cannes di delle queste scaglie dorate
belle persone che abbiamo un arcobaleno
volendo vedere sopra slime fa e dice se
un disastro del terremoto
forse era già aperto la busta non lo sto
comunque non aveva i denti e poi come
decorare con il lecca lecca carino non
temo box coltivato català purtroppo
perché troppo divertente il cappello
apre questo si è rotto
abbiamo dei bit terzic euro a cassetta
di cortina nostri caminati greeter per
poi c'è questa busta della rotta verso
tutti la tutti a raffica di arresti
sqlite no allora nella mia cappellina
abbiamo clipper roda è viva e poi
abbiamo le massime giusto prima volta
che questo gruppo ha perso questi sono i
nostri ingredienti e tra una piano per
tutti
è vero la grande privati asciutti
moscato l'altro primi aspettare dai
altri la crema idratante azione e questo
è vero ma ci credo
cosa hai fatto c'è ovviamente vitale un
piatto che fa tanto per terra abbiamo
messi quale sono bellissime si può le
colorate abbiamo le palline che per
dirti con baird e keith allen e tali
sono le 40 tesi che dovevo mettere un
bigliettino qua dentro consiglio con la
bianca con la trans pratica che non si
sa praticamente siccome la sono
dimenticata la colla sarà scelta per
faccia volta all'ora
la mia scatola con la viola con i
glitter quindi pensa che così bene
allora palline rota poetico consigliate
bianca consiglio per l'expo color terra
e poi okite azzurri allora senza che
questo stress questi spendano super
colorati sicuramente non vedo l'ora di
vedere come una forma questa cosa
possiamo decidere queste bianco prospect
quello che poi non sono sicuro non
l'abbiamo
insomma ok
e quanto bianca lasciando ancora
trasparente proprio perché ho un sacco
di decorazioni formate quindi per
pensare la squadra trasparente bene
inizia subito vedendo la colla e di
uscire saperlo prima
ok io faccio il mio pesca vediamo che
queste ma colori anomine quel che sembra
un po color pesca guardate secondo voi è
color pesca o non è color pesca sta
scrivetemi nei commenti il mio la emma
invece è color line con fido meno male
che capita adesso recuperiamo pratica
perde biagi allora io passo a rischio e
con dico niente lo corretto subito la
firma da quando ingrediente e per certo
un color fest e pensi a me che quanto
tutto
aspetto ancora girando aspetterebbe che
prima di allora mette glitter viola
adesso che su questo secolo
ecco
ma guardate che bello se questi glitter
sono bellissimi perché sono il cerchio
un cerchietto rosa e poi colore
bellissimo
wow vediamo il tuo vediamo un po come il
tuo il mio cuore ci ho messo per ore non
si vede molti film o perché sono
bravissimi passo possiamo aiutare la
parola trasparente aspetta verrai fra
bellissimo vede il jungle online sta
facendo uno slay un po sporco e uno
slide bellissima la differenza se letti
vediamo che fanno fatica proposta e tu
quelli glitter ai io ho già aggiunto con
diversi e ci sono questi reati acqua
elemento poni però perché non ha troppo
verde lo studio prendendo di colore no
ma che è già bellissimo
[Musica]
ma diamo gli altri kit prosa il teatro
per questo ho paura di farmi questo
piano
mi raccomando come possiamo vedere c'è
già il color la i pezzettini verdi e
limone e il giallo del corpo interesse
per affo ride lo slime spray le certezze
ad affrontare no ancora non ho messo per
caso non mettiamo la decorazione del
limone con certa gente a torino e in un
istituto dimensione riemerge dicevo
prima questo si può chiamare anche slime
mojito abbiamo il limone lamenta di
quanto e glitter
a mettere le conchiglie eccoci qua
[Musica]
sirena finalmente mentre tu
considerazione come seduto vicino la
bambina sta che questa volta con il
vantaggio e vedremo meno umani unire
capitato per perde il nostro come fatto
estremo di distratta dosato quindi
niente aumento
[Risate]
[Musica]
come mai le carte per colpire sono tutti
nei permessi
qua io non voglio creare questo neghino
di tortura reale che si tratti quasi
pronta sto dicendo line così non la vede
mai visto del mondo la cina religioso
che è successa è deve essere un attimo
rettificato bicarbonato o anche le
patine non si attaccano berna le acli
killer pubblica quando sfratto la
presentazione è già pronto addirittura
il mio fascicolo creato ma non perché
amo i denti aspettare sono pronto
victor micro scuola detta questa cosa di
tre medici
ok siamo pronti siete pronti a portare
tutto il pronto per la trattazione sono
prontissimo
ecco il mio bellissimo slime color line
più un colore molto delicato io nel male
carino diciamo la verità si sa è molto
carino e poi a queste questo bellissimo
arcobaleno qua dietro con le nuvolette e
che dà ancora più che dopo ancora più
colore noi abbiamo tutte nelle nostre
piccole palline colorate qualche
pezzettino di lime del limone quella che
adesso non si vede non si trova perché
all'interno e poi niente procediamo
subito danni ma i suoni
ma come mai questo booking semmai più
mettendo la pizza i miei slang con e con
i suoni migliori sun testi ricordate che
accorpare i bellissimi queste sfumature
di verde giallo palline che cadono la
frutta va dai stupendi proprio quel
super elastico super flessibile
superbello super per di pezzi perso
qualche pallina benham in porta
e bello che bello poi di nuovi rumori
senti quelli sono effetti speciali
effetti sonori bellissime bellissime per
la bellezza e soprattutto mi raccomando
hashtag mi dispiace anita ma questa
volta in solitaria
lo stesso hashtag stupendo bene posso
andare io deve continuare
dai su ecco qua il mio slime clicchiamo
anche il lecca lecca sopra la smetti
eccolo qua allora a un tacco di clipper
e la maggior parte diciamo il colore più
che altro è rosa a palline questi sono i
suoni
non perde i pezzi come quello di evitare
[Applauso]
a proposito tu l'hai detto il nome per
il tuo slime lo sly una super vantare
una mera limoni lines come gerrard hanks
pulsante
il mio non so come chiamarlo è molto
rosa quindi lo chiamerò dai da me un
bottiglia tu che hai tanta fantasia rosa
pesca ma non è pesca la pesca lime super
rosa rosa fuggito perché agita come
sembrano rosa antico la rosa con gb 10
quindi quel tempio time votate
volevo solo ricordare che il mio slime
assolto due piccolissimi difetti il
primo è che perde qualche pallina perché
le colline purtroppo sono sferiche
quelle carlo il secondo è che è troppo
troppo bello questo l'unico di ferie ma
dietro pechino che formano del difetto
di al troppo bello che permettono lo
slime spumeggiante lines slice come già
l'anno area scrivete nei commenti i
punti fermi il leinster aspetto e per
sony è quello di vita per aspetto per
sony e fateci sapere se un trio o
strumento vitale lo slang spumeggiante
direttore e ora vi lasciamo pappato
cartellino esco cliccare se volete
vedere le nostre altre sale vieni times
video divertenti cliccate su quella che
frequente e buona visione
ciao ramo